[Applause]
Liggins with a steel
[Applause]
Stauskas gets it right back
but a job by a Kogi that time getting
into the cut again great and then jobs
can't finish in transition but Tolliver
there for the putback see if the
Timberwolves can close out this final
two minutes plus with a little flurry
Andrew Wiggins to close that gap reads
well sure able to bake 20 fortunate Jim
this one really fortunate to go in but
he had to take it because Isis and
through the hope comes up with the
defensive play to squirt the basketball
three rows attaching Gallinari and
they're finished in can they climbed
this hill in LA
Jayla with one of those crushing screens
mutlar inside the Wiggins and both teams
we've seen details of a really good
three-point beautifully but he's also
unstoppable down low as Rhodes launches
hets
Derrick Rose for five from that distance
when he was healthy and whole
legendary workouts in Santa Monica
California two wolves had made the last
six shots before that empty trip Andrew
Wiggins with the block on Joe Harris
[Applause]
hitting him from running cutting
attacked in the offensive glass and
Duncan versus just standing on the
perimeter watching the game or five
Timberwolves in double figures and
Andrew Wiggins up the turnover has an
open floor and Andrew with his fourth
Duncan season
sym rolls with her first scary two-wire
with you and on the season and he's also
dealing dives from down there as well
but left boxes great flourishes
temporals me time to miss 10 of 12 not
anymore
Andrew Wiggins from downtown his first
triple look at the pressure but that
young Memphis puts on a great spin move
by Ricketts who rises for the stop takes
him on and then spins away from him the
help wasn't there but he collapsed like
they normally happened it was just a
wide-open area for him to roll into sin
Witte loses the basketball but it gets
knocked right in the hands of Carroll
and then the temporal stick when they
finally do force a turnover little ball
pressure and active hands by Andrew
Wiggins and what a finish my team
sex team swatted away by witness be
physical they get it to compel
underneath again but company will take
it away Wiggins came in there though and
knocked them off and certainly did
momentum that they need as they try to
climb their way out of this hole he
finished that second quarter was a big
energy boost hard and attacks rattles
off the rim
Gibson fighting Whitman and they're
gonna sing the name was stepping out of
bounds
Timberwolves basketball Artemis he stays
on his hip gets up there and gets a
piece of the basketball just rolls off
times gives Wiggins Gibson fighting for
towns comes down with it can't get it to
go Andrew Wiggins isn't leaped out of
the gym like he had a pogo stick
broadcast the Billy Hernan Gomez
Riggins one for Andrew would he jump his
corner if you listen to the top pivotal
post game when he talks about Andrew
Wiggins he says enters getting his
rhythm back and Riggins the spin move
kicks it out Gibson / three get it then
wow what a bounce for Taj Gibson this is
called a friendly bounce Andrew Wiggins
on the spinner dishes about does Gibson
who spaced out to the corner clam beer
like that or not like that I'm not a
hundred percent sugar win side of the
coin I'd fall on that are maybe it's a
crazy now Andrew Wiggins following the
play comes up with a block back after
bowls we're gonna set a chance with a
fresh 14 Wiggins way downtown a splashes
it over splash curry
shot clock yep down to three and true
drills the three make a ton the
three-point differential the rosin
fumbles it away Tyus Jones has toss
Gibson with him Tyus it's an extra gear
toss follows it up we are ready to stop
the bleeding and we're ready to stop
feeling sorry for ourselves then we will
be alright David Jeff whew what a spin
move by Andrew Wiggins for the bucket
thank you very much Marty yeah teams
they're just doing huge damage from
outside the arc no Casey they're gonna
get the volume the shots up but they're
not a good two point shooting team is
cut by Wiggins answer with the chance
for the Antoine and juegos the lake pass
by Carl Anthony towns I told you some
things you didn't yes you did
which gets annoying just in time beats
the buzzer with the bucket for 10 points
per game on the season is of the corner
I really took those two off when we
thought the shot grazed the rim and the
shot clock expired Wiggins oh my
goodness elevation alikat tires
challenge hands like the the game he had
yesterday in Miami was just wow Wiggins
injured out there with his elbow was
here with 14 nice pass by towns to
Wiggins above the break as well
[Applause]
trampoline action for andrew wiggins son
andrew wiggins throws it down with a
patek stop that but he was an Iron Man
out there he's you alone out there and
he's used to taking some and throw it
you can see that coming now it's just
unabated third in this building towns
kick into the corner
[Applause]
Wigan town the shot clock winding down
and he buries it
three to shoot gets it away and Andrew
drills it right as the buzzer goes off
into loaves played here in Oklahoma City
one of the things he's been doing he's
even tried to confuse and sort of
relaxes brave little bit by his andrew
wiggins hammers mile pass picked off by
towns has Wiggins ahead of the field and
he puts it down and t-wolves
short-handed and the backcourt that is
the reason receive Jared Terrell Wiggins
pretty long range and the demons have
their biggest lead over my two three
four Wigan as two games just each of 21
from the field
one or two tonight four to shoot for
Wiggins and Andrew we talked about at
the top of the broadcast his numbers
from downtown symbols hanging tough on
the back end of a back-to-back case six
point lead midway through the first a
bit overmatched is a small forward
especially defensively offensively he's
fine
Wiggins Wow contested jumper and then
some by Angelique Wiggins working a
little two-man game with Taj Gibson and
how pretty was that operating in ball
screen action avoiding Joe angles and
then go bears playing dropped coverage
and he's dropped so much Couchbase took
that deer job everyone's got to go to
work on Wednesday morning this cold
outside town gets over the top grace
O'Neill is he defensive concept there
what it takes to guard a great player
like Donovan Mitchell beautiful pass by
karl-anthony towns had to Wiggins
absorbs the contact and he'll have a
chance for a three-point play
Wiggins he got O'Neal lean to the wrong
way feeds Gordy out of the corner for
three
Corki Chang is 12th triple of the season
are so worried about players and coaches
and family leaving that city because
it's not little space that's not in LA
Walt a three-night by Jang Timberwolves
have time Wiggins turning it up the
floor has Craig on him
Andrew pulls up and one of those shots
when Andrew takes it you have a feeling
he's gonna make it cuz it's a tough shot
Wiggins spin move can't get it to drop
but follows his own miss with point warm
lap at 21 pounds being guarded dogged
Lee by Conley who comes up with the
basketball Conley is third steal tonight
but Wiggins get that shot here's the
interim coach from Minnesota said that
they talked about it before their
Orlando game what they need to do to get
into the playoff sees Wiggins with a
strong shaking finish
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wiggins tiller wrap me out of the corner
Josh can't nail down the three
[Applause]
knowing some help five to shoot
Wiggins burrows and what pines credit
Anson Wiggins for creating that play
[Music]
Wiggins finds Corki Chang
morgy his first points of the game you
see the sense of urgency steam ahead and
cut back on towns that time 17 and 5
going back to last season yes yes this
is his 10th WL [ __ ] yes we have you
seen Gorky Jane play with karl-anthony
towns very much in a long time Andrew
Wiggins deep three so you got two point
guards and you got two centers playing
along with Andrew Wiggins butanna
9 to 2 run
useless it's been towns just creating
shot for himself charge the extra pass
to wake it to the corner for the three
ball on a baby
unbelievable play how about the pass by
charge kind of knocked away out of his
hands but 36th game this year with at
least five made threes how many games if
the Tibbles played this season where
they have gotten five as a team
well isn't Murray just the Ambassador
from Minnesota basketball marty is the
ambassador for all things in the Senate
there are lands
and as the Riggins will head to the
free-throw line Reagan's three throws it
over the top of Valanciunas to go
checking out the elbow diet on bass
nice little catalyst here man air hisses
you know giving him the basketball
reminds me of old Andrew Wiggin
Gordy James is an excellent screener and
now he's sneaking into the paint he's
doing a nice job sneaking back to his
right hand getting downhill but this is
what I say about Georgie Jeff Tim Balz
winning this quarter 3212 make it 32 to
12
still shooting 64% andrew wiggins to
Joshua Cody February 7th a acquire John
Michael green and Garrett temple from
Memphis for Avery Bradley and to Wiggins
a chance for an and-one
Jimmy Butler was sitting on that
rotational pass by ties Jones and great
decision by tires before the contact to
get tires the Skip pass across court to
enter it's the most he's had and a
Mavericks uniform as your Wiggins
thank you very much leo we'll get you
back to Minneapolis for our halftime
festivities someone who we did see in
that last game one opportunity or
Franchi Wigan Andrew Wiggins as an
active cutter Gideon karl-anthony towns
into a handoff situation the defender
dion Waiters tries to get into the cut
and take away that handoff sheet Andrew
Wiggins Moore has had a nice night 15
points two blocks and to a records
fishness Lee attacks the rim another
backdoor cut by Andrew Wiggins we need
to get off to a good start here
defensively lost the second
[Music]
[Applause]
that hot start in while Paul George just
2 of 11 from the field and Wiggins who
also had a hot start next act another
3/4 on an easy shot
jab steppin little one dribble harden
esque step back but they're talking
about with his shot is that he tends to
load it up and his hands are in his eye
level
andrew is just unbelievable right now
Minnesota's actually won the battle from
downtown in this game they've made seven
threes totally five for Denver now
they're gonna get a three-point play
possibly the old-fashioned way see how
yogic with underside what's up you guys
this Taylor Brooks with bleacher report
make sure that you subscribe for some
more video content